the eu is considering whether to label
nuclear power as green that could make
atomic energy eligible for investments
aimed at making the future carbon free
and today is the last day for countries
to object to the plan which has been
controversial from the start overall 13
eu countries use nuclear power
generating just over a quarter of the
blocks electricity but there are huge
differences between countries in recent
years france got almost 70 percent of
his electricity from its 58 reactors the
share in germany was down to 11 in 2020
and the government here is shutting down
the last three remaining nuclear nuclear
reactors this year belgium says it wants
to phase out nuclear by 2025 and spain
by 2035.
meanwhile france plans up to plans to
ramp up adding six new reactors slovakia
and finland are also building new
facilities and poland has long said it
wants to build its own
so this issue has exposed a fault line
between the eu's major powers germany's
position is largely that the risks of
nuclear accidents outweigh the benefits
of climate-friendly and reliable energy
production but the french and others say
nuclear power must be an essential part
of transitioning away from carbon-based
fuels like coal
fukushima
a nuclear disaster that shook the world
in 2011 and changed the way many people
view nuclear energy
andre shaq says fukushima mobilized him
the french anti-nuclear activists
traveled to japan after the catastrophe
for me this looked like the end of the
world from this moment on i really asked
myself about the risk that the
population is exposed to especially
women and children when living next to a
nuclear reactor or other nuclear
facilities being exposed to possible
nuclear accidents
while some eu countries decided to phase
out nuclear energy after fukushima
france stuck to its nuclear tradition
more than 50 nuclear reactors are spread
over the territory right now clearly a
wrong choice andres axis
the 70 year old lives on a peninsula in
normandy northern france that is well
known for its natural beauty
and for its high number of nuclear
facilities
france derives about 70 percent of its
electricity from nuclear plants like
this one here in flamma wheel udf
electricity of france a largely
state-owned company operates these
nuclear plants and says they are safe
and strictly monitored
critics like andre jacques think
differently
the older nuclear power plants get the
higher the risk of accidents you really
cannot say they are infallible
finally nuclear power plants produce
nuclear waste
here in la arc close to the activist's
hometown a plant processes nuclear waste
the factory is the region's biggest
employer
at this local debate on further
investments in nuclear power residents
also bring up the huge risks
but the company's spokesman says nuclear
is better than gas and carbon
we're facing a climate emergency and
global warming and even if nuclear power
was not designed for this purpose it now
represents a huge advantage that it
doesn't emit lots of greenhouse gases
in its spit to become carbon neutral by
2050 france has already announced it
will start building new nuclear power
plants despite criticism from some eu
countries like germany energy expert
nicola masucci supports the french
government's move
the idea now is to develop reactors that
can be produced on an industrial level
in factories as automated as possible to
make it cheaper and guarantee quality
for andre
new technical solutions are not the
answer
he wants nuclear power to belong to the
past but france has already decided it
will be part of its future
so is nuclear power green or is it not
let's bring in folker questioning he's a
professor for renewable energy systems
at the berlin university of applied
scientists sciences and a campaigner for
wind and solar energy mr questioning if
the eu classes nuclear energy as green
germany's against it but it does look
pretty isolated there doesn't it
no not really so we have a lot of
countries in europe they don't have
nuclear power for example austria
denmark if you go to norway other we
have a lot of countries they have no
nuclear power
france of course they have a lot and
so it's a discussion
germany is not isolated clear
if the eu classifies a nuclear
as green are you worried there will be
less funding available for projects with
regard to solar and wind energy
yeah it could be because
new nuclear power stations are very
expensive so you have to spend a lot of
money there are more than three or four
times more expensive than investment in
solar and wind energy so if we are going
to nuclear power the money is missing
for the way for the renewables and to
become carbon dioxide free so for my
opinion it's no good idea to
spend money in new nuclear power
installations
uh talking about co2 the nuclear
proponents say that nuclear is nearly
co2 free and reliable and scalable
shouldn't it at least be part of the
solution in the fight against climate
change for an industrial especially for
an industrial industrialized nation like
germany
and we know that we need uh for most
wind power and
solar power for cover our future
electricity and energy demand so and
these technologies they are fluctuating
so we have
fluctuations in the energy supply and
nuclear power is not a very good
option to cover the remaining energy
supply because
power station yeah they are they are
they are produced to produce electricity
all over the day continuously and that's
not possible in the future energy supply
with a high share of solar and wind
power and for that nuclear power is no
option and nuclear power is expensive so
it's really expensive so we have
expensive technology with high risk
that's not very good compatible to
supply with solar and wind power and for
that reason it's better to go to
renewable technologies
let's have a look at the future
in a study that you conducted in 2016
you found that the push for renewables
needs to happen at around four to five
times at the speed that we are doing it
now if we are looking at a growing
resistance again for example wind power
in in the countryside in germany do you
think that's realistic that we can scale
up so massively
yeah we have to do
and
if you look at that context so nuclear
power is also no option so at the moment
nuclear power covers three percent of
the german
energy demand so if nuclear power should
make a part for for climate protection
so we have to install 100 new nuclear
power stations so if the german people
also are afraid of which 100 or even
more and that's not possible because
you we have also some problems to
install wind power stations you can
imagine what will happen if the
government decide to install new nuclear
power stations so it's a ridiculous
discussion here
what do you think
again looking at the future about the
new generation of smaller nuclear plants
that could even burn the existing
nuclear waste that we have lying around
now this
nuclear power stations only exist on
paper we have no real power stations and
we know that we have to become carbon
dioxide free way fast so in germany we
have 15 to 20 years time to become
carbon dioxide free we have not the time
to make experiments for another 10 or 15
years to look if these nuclear power
stations may work and then we need
another 20 or 30 years to install a high
number of nuclear power stations this
technology is too late it's too
expensive and too risky
for questioning thank you very much for
your input
you're welcome
well friday actually sees the end of a
consultation on the eu's plans to label
nuclear power and natural gas as well as
green investments and open them up to
more funding so let's discuss the plans
further with claudia kempfort from the
german institute of economic research
thanks for joining us on dw business can
you first of all just explain to us
why the european commission feels it
needs for natural gas and nuclear to be
designated as green
well first of all we need a regulation
that defines the requirements what is
really a financial product that is green
and sustainable and
nuclear
obviously is not green it's risky it's
costly and it also it's not sustainable
at all so and on the other hand also for
fossil natural gas is not sustainable
because it creates high emissions and
both should not belong to this eu
regulation or this taxonomy because we
need to
channel the investments into renewable
energy into energy savings and electric
mobility and all this and both
technologies nuclear and foster natural
gas hinder the transition so that's why
it's so important but the argument of
course for
both of those is that they are essential
to getting us to a point where we have
enough energy we're emitting less carbon
dioxide
in the meantime in the meanwhile while
we don't have the renewable sources to
make up for it
well the most important thing is that we
have now to invest because
right now we have a certain share of
nuclear natural gas right now in the
system but it needs to be
declined because natural gas is too
emission intensive and nuclear is too
costly it also takes a lot of time to
construct the power plants look at the
most
recent
buildings of this power plant it takes a
decade or more we don't have this time
we need to invest right now into
renewable energy into really a green
transition and this is why it's so
important to channel right now the
investments into real
future technologies and not those which
hinder the transition
do you think there's a chance the
european commission is rethinking this
need to designate natural gas in
particular is green given the way that
relations are going with russia and the
fact that it appears that natural gas is
perhaps not the reliable um there's not
this reliable stream of it that we
thought there might have been
yeah i would hope so because right now
as you describe
russia and geopolitical risk we have
right now we have to reduce the share of
natural gas in the system so if germany
would really decline
and would say this natural gas is not
part of the eu taxonomy and france on
the other hand says nuclear is not we
would have the best solution and
hopefully this will happen that they
both agree in the military to say and
then we have would have an eu taxonomy
which really drives the investments into
a full uh renewable energy system
because that's the best system well the
months ahead are going to tell us what
the results of that
consultation were claudia kempfort thank
you very much for joining us
thank you
you